nouvelle vidéo donc nouveaux t-shirts et
flemme de repasser donc sèche linge et
salut il ya quelques semaines lumière
vous est proposé un nouveau concept
faire une alfa q je crois pas que ça a
déjà été fait mais peut-être que je me
trompe je connais pas tout internet on
peut le principe était que vous
m'envoyer vos questions par un google
forme et que je garde une cette question
par lettre de l'alphabet donc une
question qui commence par à une part b
et c
donc il y a pour le mans de tambours
invisible 26 question exactement
j'ai donc tout envoyé à une amie
chanteuse qui s'appelle karine hersant
en lui disant voilà c'est toi qui
sélectionne une question par lettre de
l'alphabet tu me les pose dans une vidéo
et moi j'y réponds je n'ai pas encore vu
les vidéos je ne sais pas quelles sont
les questions qu'elle va me poser
merci à vous tous d'avoir participé on
en a reçu 5 milles en 24 heures elle a
eu un petit peu de travail
ces partis sont évidemment bonjour a
tous voila j'aimerais savoir comment
fais tu pour lui était de travail à
savoir youtube et les spectacles et
comment arrives-tu a trouvé encore
encore du temps lit si toutes les
questions sont aussi longs crocs va
galérer
j'ai plus de temps libre et je n'ai plus
de sommeil voilà mext manipuler personne
de l'espace commentaire car sous chaque
vidéo et d'insulter des rats si oui oui
donc on est aussi sur les questions qui
fâchent
alors je mettais à la base dit que
jamais je bannirai quelqu'un d' espace
commentaire et ça m'est arrivé pour deux
personnes cet été c'est pas tant qu'ils
étaient insultes envers moi mais envers
vous les abonnés qui commentait et
autant d insulte envers moi ça me fait
rien autant il est hors de question que
des personnes insultes gratuitement les
gens qui commentent ou aussi les gens
qui passent dans mes vidéos chocolatines
ou pains au chocolat chocolatines la
rochelle représente
mais enfin tout le monde le sait le
monde est composé de pouce en l'air et
donc forcément si vous l'aviez pas la
vidéo ça peut créer un trou noir
non c'est sérieux c'est pour ça que tous
les youtube heures vous le rappelle est
ce que comme d'hab cévennes et les
papillons matger la mer et les oiseaux
tu as d'autres passions que le mental
les thèmes de télévision malheureusement
j'ai plein de passion mais chut ah bon
sur les rimes en onze mecs tu feras tu
feras tu
mais je kiffe tellement ce qu'ils ont
fait par les questions c'est trop grasse
et barange qui avait quelques vous ai
déjà vus sur la chaîne alors oui j'ai un
début de projet de live vous avez parlé
dans la vidéo des cent mille abonnés que
du coup je vous invite à regarder gagner
du terrain vis un moment avec les
revenus de ton spectacle avant avant
youtube avant youtube est marrante cette
question parce qu'on la pose souvent en
fait faire des spectacles
c'est mon métier depuis depuis des
années et oui c'est un métier c'est ça
qui me faisait vivre et c'est ça qui me
fait vivre d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui
youtube me permets pas du tout gagner ma
vie pleinement next
là on sent que ça lui a fait mal à
karine de dieu fera ce que tu fais pas
bien français comme je l'avais dit quoi
qu'il arrive que tu respectes exactement
les questions comme elles sont écrites
elle l'a fait mais c'était douloureux
sûrement aussi douloureux que de devoir
se lever assez tôt les matins c'est pas
le fait de se lever tôt d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas un problème c'est le fait de
continuer à se coucher tard mais de se
lever tôt d'un coup il ya ya
et comme un problème et je me suis ratée
quand même quelques paires de fois cette
année iras tu as là
ça devait être fin 2016 et du coup c'est
en 2017 j'ai déjà un truc de prévu sur
l'un des deux jours mais j'irai j'irai
en tant que comme vous en faites j'irai
me promener là bas à la bcp mais je n'ai
pas du tout eu de carton d'invitation
c'est trop intime comme question next
non mais ça c'est pareil je veux pas
répondre à ça ça regarde que moi le fait
que j'aime et j'adore la heineken non
mais jamais je me dis aurait tout le
travail que j'ai fait cette année il y
avait peut-être trop de vidéos j'en sais
rien ça arrive régulièrement qu'on me
pose une question sur une vidéo qui a
été fait dans la semaine où des gens qui
participent à un concours qui s'est
finie depuis des mois les vidéos pour le
rubik's cube je les ai mises au mois de
juillet on est au mois de novembre
et c'est terrible parce que je fais des
playlists etc j'organise au mieux la
chaîne pour que ce soit tout clair et
lisible mais pas tellement en fait après
il ya un truc qui marche à s'arrêter de
taper fabien olicard rubik's cube pour
voir si elle est désormais ou pas
mentalise ratu quelqu'un de célèbre ou
peut-être que tu l'as déjà ce faire dans
ce cas peux tu nous dire si tu as réussi
et qui on est complètement dans la suite
de la réponse de la vidéo d'avant c'est
à dire que en 327 vidéo il ya des gens
qui sont plutôt connus parfois sur la
chaîne enfin ce soit des youtuber ou des
artistes des choses comme ça enfin après
connu ça dépend de qui tu connais ou pas
tu vois il ya je fais des vidéos à
karthus pierre cros avec big seven et je
peux faire mieux que te dire si j'ai
réussi ou pas il suffit de regarder la
playlist tour de mentalisme vraiment
mashaie n'est pas claire apparemment
et tenter
j'ai même plus envie de répondre aux
questions j'ai juste envie de regarder
leurs vidéos pour les écoles j'étais à
l'école maternelle de marcilly l'école
primaire de marcilly le collège
jean-guiton à lagord et après je suis
allé au lycée
léonce vieljeux à la rochelle et pour
après tout ça il ya une vidéo qui est
prévue là dessus donc vous en parle pas
ou souhaiterais tu le plus par un
spectacle et pourquoi
car les nerfs sans en direct de
l'olympia
alors je sais pas tellement parce que
j'ai eu la chance de beaucoup beaucoup
voyagé avec mon spectacle donc je les
jouais un petit peu partout dans le
monde
pas forcément celui ci exactement mais
j'ai joué dans pas mal d'endroits et
avec celui ci je voulais quand même des
grandes scènes j'ai joué à l'olympia
pour le point virgule fait l'olympia je
suis allé jouer au festival de québec du
fait les premières parties au zénith de
jeff mann acloque j'ai fait un plateau à
bobino j'ai joué mon spectacle au point
virgule au grand point virgule j'ai fait
pas mal de trucs super cool que je
rêvais de faire je pense sûrement que
c'est assez classique mais le truc que
j'ai pas fait c'est jouer mon spectacle
entier à l'olympia je les passais en
entier là bas donc sûrement ce serait ça
surement le 6 il y avait un rêve
penses-tu qu'un jour tu vas y arriver au
1 million d'abonnés
bah aucune idée je pensais même pas
avoir cent mille personnes qui suivent
la chaîne cette année donc et en est au
double quasiment alors je sais pas si
j'atteindrai les 1 million d'abonnés un
jour d'ailleurs en parlant chiffres
comme ça mais moi je préfère parler en
personne aux millions de personnes qui
regardent les vidéos qui suivent la
chaîne
mais si ça doit arriver un jour je suis
qu'à 20% de ça en fait et 20% c'est pas
grand chose donc aucune idée sincèrement
aucune idée mais déjà j'ai prévu un gros
truc si un jour on atteint les 500
milles d'abonnés ce qu'ils aient de la
haye normes et je vous en parlais
également de la vidéo des cent mille
abonnés
sais tu devais choisir d'en avoir arrêté
le temps pouvoir stopper le temps
claquant des doigts et le faire repartir
en claquant des doigts et d'après vous
c'est quoi la première chose que je
ferai en stoppant le temps comme ça à
loisir je dormirai vraiment je crois que
j'en profiterai pour que pour éliminer
le sommeil de ma vie réelle et je
dormirai comme ça en pause en faisant
une pause dans le temps et je lirai
délivre aussi j'en profiterai pour lire
des livres comme ça c'est tellement bien
restreint
mais
je te soupçonne karine d'avoir
sélectionné cette question uniquement
pour faire ce trip sur m
et même des cheveux comme jean et non il
ne restera pas de couscous parce que je
mangerai tout next sachant que tu as 146
mille abonnés que comptes tu faire pour
le million les 500000 a du coup j'ai
déjà répondu à cette question
veuillez vous référer à la lettre p
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bazar cette
question et deux fois gênante
premièrement elle est gênante parce que
à cause de karine et ressent on va tout
savoir
cette musique l'un dans la tête c'est
sûr d'ici une heure ou deux vous à les
fredonner tout huit villes et vous allez
vous dire bah ouais super c'est grâce à
l'alpha qu est la deuxième chose qui est
gênant c'est que je n'ai pas de calvitie
non mais c'est quoi une calvitie c'est
ici un j'ai pas de calvitie mon gars je
pense que tu voulais parler de ce large
front un petit peu comme dans minus et
cortex et bien c'est pas que j'ai un
large front c'est que mes cheveux ont du
mal à descendre sur le front est et a
toujours été comme ça et je te déteste
une personnalité donc tu fan je suis
ultra fan d'alexandre astier de tout ce
qui fait et aussi de la personne en
elle-même voudriez vous bien poser cette
question dans vidéo est un cul s'il vous
plaît non hors de question
next mais du coup lieu
dont secret pour toujours avoir le
sourire
tu vois j'ai failli perdre parce que je
viens de voir un soucis de caméra mais
c'est bon à leur partie alors je sais
pas si j'ai toujours le sourire par
contre je suis toujours content de faire
ce que je fais et dans la vie j'ai
toujours fait ce que j'aimais faire
c'est ma seule priorité
et quand tu fais toujours ce que tu
aimes que ça marche ou pas tu es quand
même content en fait de l'avoir fait du
résultat
le succès d'un projet et la réussite de
faire ce que tu aimes faire tous les
jours sont deux choses différentes et ça
me fout la patate x plus de + 4 / soit
égale 5x égale combien alors j'essaye de
ne pas tricher c'était x plus de +4 donc
x + 6 sur trois gars 5 donc x + 6 égale
15 donc illégal 15.6 donc x égale 9,6 me
suis pas trompé dans l'annoncé et si je
me suis planté je prends souvent
entendre parler dans les commentaires
oui il ya des projets en cours mais je
fais pas trop vous en parler
principalement parce que j'aime bien
parler des choses quand elles sont sûres
et puis aussi parce que j'aimerais bien
vous faire des surprises mais je vous en
parle à vis du clan de soirée
j'ai oublié le nom de la béquille
quoi
poser des questions je peux lui poser
les questions
bah oui tu marques sans numéro de
téléphone tu lui demandes et puis après
tu lui demandes de thé pelé son prénom
et puis elle va te les peler et si elle
dit iba der génie ça s'écrit à virginie
tu vénères pliure toi que j'ai rencontré
un jour une guerre finie avec un y est
je veux pas vexer maintenant et tu
bidouille un petit peu ainsi s'achève
l'alpha qu un concept
autrement dit à l'elfe accusés pour
cette 26 questions je pense que cette
vidéo doit être très très longues et
j'en suis très content pourquoi parce
que karine m'a chanté toutes les
questions merci karine avec animaux
ressaisir alors cette fille-là fait ma
rockstar en fait j'ai un couple de
rockstar à moi rien qu'à moi c'est
karine et victor barange que vous avez
déjà vu plein de fois sur la chaîne
barange lavaud dit oui
karine j'aime trop ce qu'elle fait
j'aime trop savoir et où est ce que je
peux l'entendre chanter une bonne
question est bas sur youtube mon pote et
aussi en vrai sur youtube vous mets le
lien dans la description tu as une
chaîne youtube
oui s'appelle c'est du mentalisme attend
bouge pas il s'appelle karine et ressent
comme vous êtes mentalist vous sentez
que c'est très actif chaîne youtube et
je pense que si vous arrivez comme ça
sur sa chaîne
ça va le motiver à sortir encore plus de
choses et moi je serai le 22 décembre au
bateau le nez rouge je sais que c'est
pas la date que je vous ai annoncé du
tout mais c'est karine garçon qui joue
là bas
et moi je veux venir te voir c'est déjà
une place et et vous aussi peut-être si
ça vous tente si vous êtes sur paris
venez c'est une seule date et c'est le
22 décembre
et en plus on se croisera là bas et on
applaudira tous karine aux hommes c'est
ça hein
si vous connaissez pas ça c'est que vous
connaissez pas les chansons de karine
hersant et vous allez qui fait ça venez
le 22 décembre c'est super cool
et là attention je fais ça il ya un
bouton pour s'abonner à la chaîne de
karine kabuto pour s'abonner à la chaîne
de victor merci à vous et doit regarder
la vidéo n'oubliez pas de laisser un
pouce en l'air il vous abonner en
cliquant ici par exemple peut être et
surtout à eux deux c'est une vidéo par
jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
ciao
balla lô